[Music]  kingsman world's finest tailor  but now we're going into the spy  business  very clever based on true events  this will not be a war of heroes  [Music]  meet history's most evil legends  the assassin gavrilo princip weakness  throwing arms  strength  started world war one  the super spy  mata hari strength  screen presence  weakness  scarves do you forget your manners  guilty as charged  have a crazed monkey  respiratory strengths  and weaknesses  [Music]  you'll have to see it for yourself  it's good now yes  on december 22nd our enemies think we  are gentlemen  it's time to remind them  what the kingsmen are  [Music]  nobility is born  in blood  [Music]  [Music]  boys are always so messy  the king's man only in theaters december  22nd  [Music]  you